[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
two undefeated teams two winless teams
two BOCES two errands to host that'll
take you through two halves of the
season this is the BR Benning show baby
presented by the Caesars Palace sports
book alongside our betting insider Kelly
Kiki Stewart I'm Gabby Richard's the
ain't no Niners won on Thursday the
ain't no Patriots a part of your marquee
matchups this week the bank keeps
building with her best bets
that's right cabbie we snuck through
that back door with the Giants plus six
and a half sometimes it's better to be
lucky than good we've now hit six best
bets in a row improving our season
record two seven one we've got another
one coming up at the end of the show
let's go
first up the marquee matchups of the
week we're gonna start off with the
Vikings - four and a half of the Chiefs
total of 46 we all know I don't love to
lay Road chalk here but I have no choice
but the side with the Vikings Zimmer
sixteen and five against the spread in
his last 21 versus the AFC +62 no
against the spread one coming off
consecutive wins we knew all week
mahomes wasn't healthy we knew he wasn't
gonna play yet these guys left it off
the board because they didn't want to
risk it so I on the other side of Kirk
Cousins who does well against these less
than mediocre defenses speaking of
Defense's Minnesota might be the best
defense in the NFL bigs faced on
strength of schedule I'm gonna lay the
four and a half here with the Vikings
and next up a game that has had me in a
glass case of emotions all week
Packers - four at the chargers total of
49
I like the Chargers early on I went back
to the well with the Packers the math
says Chargers the situation says Green
Bay the sports books are gonna be
cheering really hard for the Chargers
but I'm not sure it's gonna matter
because Green Bay has won and covered
all of their road games this season
Aaron Rodgers is out for blood it's
apparent if this game was in Lambeau I
might consider betting the Chargers but
it's not there are at home in the soccer
stadium where they've lost three
straight outright and failed to cover
four straight at home this season
they're just now 2 and 9 vs. line since
2018 as a host I leaned with the Packers
- four and next up the Sunday night game
Patriots - 3 at the Ravens total 44 and
a half we have the league's and number
one ranked defense versus the number two
ranked offense led by the most mobile
quarterback in the league
you guys follow me on Twitter I already
gave up my pick on Monday and if you
don't you're gonna have to wait till the
end of the show after an O and eight
starts of the season the people´s parlay
is taking a much-needed bye week which
is too bad because fading the people's
parlay has been one of the most
profitable betting strategies of 2019 my
boy Marcus even texted me this morning
how mad he was that he didn't have fade
material I told him to blame cabbie but
in an effort to improve for the second
half of the season cabbie sat down with
someone a little more knowledgeable than
the average fan as thousands of students
cram and prepare for midterms
millions of us remember that stressful
time period in our lives you lock into a
vortex in the library you bang out two
term papers who write three essays and
then you mix it a little Grand Theft
Auto as a stress reliever for all 32 NFL
teams each week is a tested here we are
at the midway point of the season
we've got Alan Berg the senior
oddsmakers for Caesars sports here thank
you so much for joining us bro listen
the public loves to bet on the favorite
/ the best teams and this season the
best teams in the NFL are also for the
best teams against the spread how is
that impacted the sports book and what
adjustments if any do you make in the
second half you know like they like you
know the Packers right now they like the
Niners right now then you see on
Thursday would happen to the Niners -
ten - ten and a half didn't cover the
spread
just be really careful as the season
goes along to get on these big popular
teams because the number starts catching
up to them eight times this season a
team has been favored by more than two
touchdowns in Las Vegas our two
touchdown point spreads the new trend
this season I think towards the end of
the season they're gonna be we're
definitely gonna see these type of teams
where certain teams are trying to make
that playoff push fight for seeding in
the playoffs against teams that maybe
are just trying to get a better draft
pick Allen which factors most inform
your decision to set the lines of the
second half of the season is it
restricted schedule is it what other
patterns for outdoor stadiums or Win
Probability what is it man I'm not
giving you the recipe man there are
certain things that have to stay behind
the counter one thing to look forward to
is when you know a Sunday night Lions
come out for the next week really watch
those line moves a lot of times that's
when sharp money's going and that might
be where you want to start placing your
bets one of the best value bets in terms
of futures in the second half of the
season well first thing I'll tell you
about a good team and I think the
Jaguars are a little underrated but also
bucks at a thousand one not the last
ticket really yeah because all they
gonna do is make the playoffs right and
if you bet on the other team to knock
them out of the playoffs you can make
yourself a little bit of money listen
with more information you're better
equipped to make sensible wagers and not
go
a gut feeling like some of us do as
Kelly always says be mindful of your
bankroll allenburg the senior odds maker
at season Sports thank you so much for
joining us man you got a better place
you can find him at % berg on twitter a
fun fall also a huge NBA guy he
mentioned the Jaguars who are think a
little behind the Texas right now there
are potentially three teams that Mike
made the playoffs from that AFC South
Jags might have to get in that wild-card
but Kelly what do you think of Alan's
insights yeah after this morning's game
we need the Jags get in that wild-card
Allen is a super sharp guy I've done a
lot of work with him over the years so I
totally respect his opinion I'd love for
that Jags plus 425 ticket to when they
AFC South would be amazing but after
today's game I don't think it's gonna
happen we'll see it's there along a long
run there while we wrap up our midseason
recap I'm sure the fans on social or
wondering how my picks have been doing
so for the first eight weeks of the
season the NFL bets I've given out on
this show and on social @br underscore
betting are 35 and 28 a winning
percentage of fifty five point six
percent and while that might not sound
impressive to you to those of you on
social media remember you need to win
fifty two point three eight percent of
your bets to just break even so we are
making money in the NFL the hardest
sport to handicap and when you look at
my best bets the games that I'm most
confident in seven and one on the season
good for an eighty seven and a half
percent win rate
alright cabbie let's try to find some
more winners as we look at my card for
week number nine I'm gonna start off on
the West Coast liance was two and a half
at the Raiders total of 51 there's been
a lot of rumors swirling this week about
Matthew Stafford's health but that
doesn't matter either way we're fading
the Lions for third week in a row to
eight and one against to spend their
last 11 games on the west coast Oakland
yes they've had a tough schedule as of
late but they are back home where
they've covered five of their last six
I like the Raiders - two and a half all
right the Bucs plus 5 at the Seahawks
total 51 and a half clearly I'm a
glutton for punishment I was on the Bucs
last week they should have won that game
Thank You zebras for bailing out the
Titans once again
yes Tampa Bay 11 turnovers in their last
two games is just mind-boggling
this is not a play on the Bucs but a
play against the Seahawks go to Seattle
of on deck divisional rival undefeated
San Francisco 49ers Monday Night
Football
Plus Seattle hasn't won a game at home
by more than a point all season the
bookmakers are toying with your emotions
they are gobbling up every Seattle
Seahawks back they can get in their
hands why because the Bucs are gonna
cover this game Colts now plus 1 at the
Steelers total 40 and a half this one's
bounce back and forth all day I can't
believe the Steelers finally rock the
line they should be they should have
been a favorite in this game why cuz
they own this Colts team sure the
quarterbacks are different than in the
past but Pittsburghers won five straight
versus Indianapolis to know hey this man
right here he's gonna have a big game
against that weak cold secondary this
line was the biggest surprise of the
week I like the Steelers Browns - four
and a half at the Broncos total 39
here's a question you have to ask
yourself are you really ready to lay
points on the road with the Cleveland
Browns come on man they can't get a
cover to save their lives I know on the
flip side the next question you're
asking yourself is who's Brandon Allen
well who knows kind of I had to Google
and I'm not gonna lie but he is not a
five-point drop-off from Joe Flacco
period Broncos plus four-and-a-half is
the play Titans was three and a half at
the Panthers total of 42 this is an
interesting dichotomy between these two
teams because you have the Titans who
got gifted their last two wins and you
got the Carolina Panthers who had 50
hung on them last week in San Fran more
importantly I'm not sold on the Titans
going on the road with Tannehill under
center of the Titans 7 and 17 against
the spread and the last 24 Road games
versus teams with winning records
alright guys that is my card
for week number nine I love your energy
this morning very infectious after
sifting through all of the fantasy
related questions mistakenly sent to us
I was able to find some betting
questions from our bleacher report
audience here now are the minds of the
public
skee prophet asks hey Kelly I prefer
betting NFL totals what are your two
finger totals this week I'm curious to
see if we agree Jeske is an absolute
great guy give him a follow on Twitter
and he crushes NFL total so I hope we do
agree we got to go back to the well with
our money maker and that is the Denver
Broncos under they have won 15 of their
last 17 games these totals just keep
getting lower and lower Browns vs.
Broncos under 39 looks scary but it's
the play another under I really like
here is the Titans Panthers under 42
both defense show up strong in
Carolina's innovative gonzo wants to
know do you ever bet the one the minus
145 range bets that you think are
winners or give a max number that you
won't play sure I laid 150 last night in
the UFC I just don't like to do it in
football I'd rather take our other lay
the two and a half points games rarely
land one or two then try to lay big
chalk as my buddy always says chocolate
hurts when it loses and when those minus
170 s minus 190 s lose it hurts twice as
bad shout-out to a Jorge Masvidal and
wearing the be the BMF belt
okay so jefe queso wants to know the
better bet Patriots 16 or no or dolphins
Owen 16 oh I don't know if one is a
better bet here here the current odds at
Caesar's Palace
Patriots yes plus 550 no minus 800
dolphins to go Owen 16 yes plus 500 no -
700 honestly I don't like either one of
these bets but if you're gonna make me
choose Eileen Pats no - $8 Kelly you
teased that earlier in the show the game
of the week the Ravens and the Patriots
it's Sunday night let's go for seven in
a row give the people your best bet
we've been rockin and rollin this NFL
season my best bet cash again last week
with the Giants was six and a half we've
now hit six straight best bets I'm
looking to make it seven with the Ravens
I tweeted this out on Monday I hope you
guys got the three in the hook because
it's down to three no chance this was
going back up all the Patriots money in
the world is pouring in these guys are
over there waiting in line they can't
wait to gobble up the Patriots and why
not because Bill Belichick and Tom Brady
have been monsters against the spread in
Foxborough boys and girls this game is
in Baltimore New England fate has faced
the easy schedule in the NFL this will
only be the second team with a winning
record they faced all year when was the
last time Cappy I faded this team oh
that's right in Buffalo and what
happened this is a classic pros vs.
Jones games almost 76 percent of the
sorry 70 percent of the tickets are on
New England Ravens plus three ravens
moneyline Ravens win that game all right
guys let's recap all of my picks for
week 9 there's almost an order of
confidence on how many units I would
recommend you bet in each so we've got a
four unit play on the Ravens three units
on the Raiders Bucks and Steelers
remember a unit is their standard bet
amount should be 1% of your bankroll
I've also got a two unit play on the
Vikings Broncos and Panthers funders and
the Browns Broncos game and Titans
Panthers game Kelly's coming out firing
in the second half of the season with
the 9 picks thank you very much for
joining us on the be our vetting show
presented by the Caesars Palace sports
book follow our football journey on
social add br underscore betting good
luck on all your bets and here's to a
profitable Sunday
[Music]
you
you